hi everyone I'm Sam Copeland with chess.com
recently we've launched a number of new features
and updates to game review and I'm here to
tell you all about them first up report cards
unlike the ones you get in school these are
fun and useful the first thing you'll see
is a summary from your coach describing how
the game went below that you will see a performance
rating for the game an estimate of your level
of play based on that single game previously
we've received a lot of questions about what
rating your accuracy for a particular game
might equal well this is that answer additionally
you'll get a quick grade for each phase of
the game based on your opening middle game
and in-game play grades are displayed as move
classifications ranging from blonder to brilliant
this should help you know exactly where you
need to improve and for more data check out
chess.com insights or chess.com stats next
up we've made two significant improvements
to classifications we have introduced a new
classification miss a Miss happens when a
player fails to take advantage of a tactical
opportunity such as finding Checkmate or punishing
an opponent's bad move however a Miss does
not indicate that the move you played was
a bad idea in general for example if you had
an advantage your opponent made an error allowing
a winning combination and you failed to find
the combination but you did keep your advantage
this would have been considered a mistake
or a blunder but now it will more accurately
be considered a Miss we've also recalibrated
how the blunder classification Works making
it more meaningful and useful now a blender
must not only drop the positions evaluation
significantly it must also lose material or
allow Checkmate we think this is how most
expert chess coaches would describe a blunder
it is not about some loss of eval according
to a computer it is about creating a tangible
exploitable opportunity for the opponent a
mostly behind the scenes Improvement is that
we have completely overhauled our book database
it should now better match well-known opening
Theory we've added known opening moves to
the book classification and we are removing
book modes that are simply bad moves we've
also recognized that sometimes coaches feedback
can be hard to follow you can now have Coach
draw arrows and highlight squares over the
board to help you understand the advice you
can do this by hovering over or clicking on
the highlighted words in coach's explanation
of a particular move with this you can much
more easily visualize the pieces tactics and
ideas that coach refers to and last but certainly
not least we've given coach more in-depth
move explanations coach now helps you to see
all of the threats behind each move and whether
those threats are prevented or allowed the
coach will also mention specific pieces so
you'll know if coach is talking about a night
Bishop Rook or any other piece we are constantly
working to improve coach's explanations so
if you haven't taken a close look at the explanations
lately give them another try and let us know
what you think the new game review experience
is available on chess.com right now and look
for all of these features to make their way
into the apps later this year foreign